the President of the United States has
taken to Twitter to make the point that
he could beat up the former Vice
President Joe Biden not normally an
issue for presidents right which former
presidents and vice presidents they
could beat up in a fight not the type of
thing you expect most presidents to talk
about but this is not most presidents
and the way that this started is that
Joe Biden recently spoke at a rally
against sexual assault at the University
of Miami and there Joe Biden said is
sort of in relation to Trump's serial
sexual assault accusations Biden said
quote a guy who ended up becoming our
national leader said I can grab a woman
anywhere and she likes it if I were in
high school I take him behind the gym
and beat the hell out of him and in
responds to this Donald Trump took to
Twitter yesterday morning and said quote
crazy Joe Biden is trying to act like a
tough guy actually he is weak both
mentally and physically and yet he
threatens me for the second time with
physical assault he doesn't know me but
he would go down fast and hard crying
all the way
don't threaten people Joe nothing is
more presidential and elevating of the
office of the presidency on the world
stage than a guy in his 70s threatening
another guy in his 70s with beating his
up with beating him up right this cannot
be normalized this would have been
unheard of in a prior time like can you
imagine Clinton saying he could beat up
Bush or Bush saying he could beat up
Clinton and for those who are saying and
I'm already seeing it online people
saying David if you criticize Trump
you've got to criticize Biden because
they both said they could beat up the
other guy no Joe Biden was speaking
specifically about how he would have
defended women he would have come to the
defense of women in the face of male
sexual assaulters when he was in high
school Donald Trump is just saying that
he could beat up Joe Biden right there
there really is no comparison here I
hope that some of the people in the
audience actually noticed the difference
here and by the way on the facts I'm not
a betting man I'm not into fights
I don't watch fight videos online
but I would bet on Joe Biden at any
point in their respective lives the only
way that I would bet on Trump winning
that fight is if it's 12 year old Trump
versus five year old Joe Biden right
which based on their actual ages is not
a scenario that would exist based on our
actual conception of time I'm sure that
trumps bone spurs alone would have been
a hindrance but beyond that the mostly
obese kyv the borderline obese seventy
one-year-old with the bone spurs is
going to beat up Joe Biden who I believe
is actually quite a fit and strong guy
and again it's not about that it's just
so stupid at every level and I think
more than anything it's a sign of
Crump's frustration right I mean the guy
can't get anything done he's got the
Russia scandal he's got the Cambridge
analytic a scandal multiple women
accusing him of payoffs and
non-disclosure agreements some under
threats of physical violence nothing is
going right for Trump and so he tweets
that he could beat up Joe Biden and I
think that this is more about Trump
feels cornered and sort of like he's
lost control over any of the narratives
about his administration it's not really
that he has a desire to beat up Joe
Biden right like I don't I don't
actually think that Trump really even
necessarily thinks he could beat up Joe
Biden maybe he does maybe he doesn't I
think this is all about Trump losing
control of the narrative and this gets
back to I don't remember if it was the
Monday or Tuesday show where I said this
I recently read Sun Tzu's the art of war
and in that book Sun Tzu writes you
always want to leave an army
or an enemy some way of getting out
because when the army or enemy is
completely cornered they go nuts they
act in a completely erratic way and
Trump clearly is feeling more and more
cornered here and asset I I get that
it's Trump but even for Trump I don't
think talking about beating up other 70
plus year old people on Twitter is
really what he imagined for himself five
years ago or 20 years ago or even when
he started running for president of the
United States and it is a signal that he
doesn't really know what to do anymore
he's tweeting continuing to tweet at
very odd hours about very straight
things and he can't control the Russia
story anymore he's trying desperately by
firing people he can't control that he
can't control Cambridge analytical he
can't control any of this stuff so
what's he doing he's saying he could
beat up Joe Biden and it's it's almost
depressing if I didn't feel like he was
really going a long way to destroying
the country and needs to be removed I
would almost kind of start to feel bad
for Trump but but I don't actually send
me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at the
Pakman show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show today's episode of the show
is made possible in part by brilliant
which is really an amazing website that
lets you engage in fun and interesting
problems and puzzles to learn more about
really important stuff math science
engineering the community aspect of
brilliant is great there's over 5
million members there bringing together
the knowledge and experience of their
students their educators the
professionals around the world that
develop a lot of the hands-on learning
problems that you will work through and
learning with the community makes a huge
difference right when you use brilliant
you're part of that 5 million member
community they share your curiosity and
love for math and science and the
community at brilliant also supports
your learning because you build a
connection with the subjects you're
learning by interacting with other
people studying the same material you
can get started right now by signing up
for free at brilliant org slash David
Pakman first 200 people who visit
brilliant org slash David Pakman will
get 20% off an annual premium membership
that is brilliant org forward slash
David Pakman support us by supporting
brilliant